zum make any two men hat ein video
gemacht es geht um
herzlich willkommen zu diesem video
leute sind dass unser geist ist passiert
radio so hat er reagiert auf hat gerade
auf meine anderen sicher reagiert wo ich
euch quasi zeigen wie viel ich mit den
beiden 2 millionen videoclips klick
videos ich kann gar nicht mehr reden als
190.000 macht er heute jede nacht der
haben ich habe mich irgendwie bisschen
aber ist selbst überzeugen so hat
gefühlte stunde lagen auch immer meinen
kurs geräte mit dem kot tomysl wieder 25
prozent rabatt nur über trocken also
wenn ihr abschneiden lernen wollt sech
vum auswahl ist einer der leute wo man
weiß es drauf haben sie es endlich
geschafft
auch das video mit dem monte film wenn
ihr den filter selber aufgegeben haben
möchte dann wurde ich mich hier unser
komitee das muss man jetzt aber direkt
einmal machen ich gucke jetzt war das
ein stream und danach gekonnt mehr dazu
etwas danke ohne als ein paar sekunden
später hatte ich immer noch nicht
geguckt ob ich jetzt die 200.000
abonnenten schon geknackt hat platin
druck diese leute jetzt auch im programm
sind habe aber bereits gesehen dass ich
seitdem der kurs ist ein mal verkauft
hat und wie viele jetzt genau weiß ich
aber nicht aber es kommt mir so ich bin
total gespannt ich hab's nicht gemacht
ja zu gucken sagt er dieses video an
nächstes video was sehr sehr auf
empfohlen wurde war von cumerio kennt
ihr schon mal ein video gemacht die
maria ist das alter junge mal so viel
leute im finstern pause tat jeder to
marry gefühl aber ich glaube ich das
neue video gemeint weil ich glaube dass
wir da war gemeint die instagram filter
erstellen so viel hatten wir youtube für
1 2 millionen klick video gezahlt die
leute die leute haben
meine zwei jahren krieg video okay die
schau machen aber die gezogen da hat der
welt ohne direkte der sich sogleich fast
zwei millionen klicks alle es geht um ok
hatten zwei mir und klickt video welches
video hatten zwei klicks von ihnen alle
alter spaß 2,4 millionen auf wo er sogar
mehrere
er hat einmal sex tape video von katja
das papier hat er und dass ich gehe
heimlich ein reges pc so ich kann jetzt
mal sagen dass die einnahmen nicht
unsere hoch sein werden weil die videos
sind beide sechs minuten 36 ist
natürlich der erste fehler richtig viele
einnahmen
kommst du eher auf dem video ist länger
ist also über zehn minuten ich als
ehemaliger kater bei wie weiß natürlich
bescheid aber ein video selber schuld
vielleicht 2000 2000 euro okay es ist
jetzt 2009/10 das ist immer noch ein
thema über das youtuber einfach selten
reden und genau wie die können auch über
alles offen reden leute ich suche ich
auch mal ein video mit 1,7 millionen
klicks habe ich einst gerade von diesem
monat und können wir gucken beweist dass
eine batterie hatte 2000 schon einmal
2004 ich glück jetzt mal halt tausender
jetzt manchmal traum von der heute jede
nacht der haben
die kleidung zu brechen wir gucken jetzt
einfach mal wie viele abonnenten jetzt
gekommen sind
nein sie 202 dass die 200 jetzt die
200.000 222 all das habe ich schon
gesagt dass er in kürze ihren mann
überhaupt ist und nicht nur sieht man
hier klickst du bekommen hat sondern
auch wie viele abonnenten und auch wie
viel geld wie viel geld war 990 euro hat
er verdient habe daher werde wieder
hellhörig habe kommt ungefähr 1 euro pro
1000 klicks
er sagte später auch noch im stream was
er 4000 klicks krieg den apparat bis
jetzt das heißt er wird auch ungefähr
2000 euro mit den zwei millionen videos
verdient haben wenn die cpm genau gleich
bleibt komplett anders war das bei all
meiner videos und zwar weil täglich so
viel geld eingebracht haben weil katja
krasavac und beide er so laut ich habe
ich so viel das wird nicht so viel geld
hab ich doch das wird vielleicht ein
paar hundert euro eingebracht haben
der mann hat das game verstanden wir
gucken jetzt mal direkt nach wie vielen
wir damit verdient haben 1,5 millionen
klicks und das sind 200 euro alter leute
aber man muss bei diesem video auch
gesagt froh sein dass es überhaupt
monetarisiert würde kenne diese videos
die super alt sind und die auch
empfohlen auf der startseite und
schreiben alle deine kommentare ganz
allem ein oldtimer classic ich gehe
heimlich an reviers pc und gebe alles
eine liebes aus mit aktuell 2,4
millionen klicks das video wurde sich
8,5 millionen minuten lang angeguckt da
ist echt krass das ist echt krass auf
jeden fall 36,5 taugt nur durch das eine
video hatte 36.000 neue abonnenten liege
also subscribe to das ist heftig oder es
ist einfach 18,25 prozent meiner
gesamten abonnenten die ich nur durch
dieses eine video dazu gewonnen hat
wirklich also alleine durch dieses video
da aber den leuten geld verstanden das
ist die größte ehre wenn wände ersten
auf seine video reagiert und dann auf
krasser wenn einfach lachen muss alter
und ich glaube ich jetzt mit diesem
video mit 2,4 millionen klicks
2000 euro 2008 erinnern uns bei der cp m
von vorhin die ungefähr 1,1 euro pro
1000 klicks war wenn wir bei ungefähr
2600 euro
jetzt wird auf jeden fall schmecken ja
aber was dachten sich die youtube mutter
google per ja auf jeden fall an die
sachen ja es ist ein bisschen schade wir
sind ja so einen guten klicks video aber
ist immer noch sieben euro sind sieben
und euro sieht man dass nur rund sieben
euro
und dann abhauen es ist jetzt nicht so
viel mit 200 euro an direkten haus auf
madeira kann man sich direkt ein
grundstück können und hat ausgesorgt
also mit 700 euro auf madeira
wie erwartet habe aber es ist ja
immerhin sie mal eur 77 euro sowie 80
ist drittel davon verkauft einfach so
eine villa ja auch hier der penner hat
mehr als nur ein profi dafür gegeben
aber ins profi jetzt knapp geworden
deren mann muss gibt er musste sich
getraut sich schön dass du da bist ja
ich finde auch das war der moment wo ich
eingeschalten habe freunde und ich war
ja in der wohnung will mein leben hängt
das mit und bio
die cpm passt auch in der ganzen kanal
an und wenn du mehr watch teil hasst und
mehr dies und das dann wird die cbm mal
höher
ich habe gerade noch in szene cbm zeit
ich doch gleich mal jetztzeit junge 14
also was er da so als hätte ich ein
video mit 1,7 millionen macht auf meinem
kanal aktuell ja 12.400 neue träger der
krieg der acht euro oder so pro klick
60 er weiß ja wenn über das ist aber
erst das video ist erst das video hat
die man sieht hier ganz lanka oder aber
ich können sie mal
bruder ja bisher weniger als 14 tagen
hat das einfach 12 k eingebracht gegner
kam ich sag mal so
danke an dieser stelle ruhig geld das
ist wirklich das skript ihr seht dass
ein video und es kommt jeden tag zwei
videos ich will es jetzt wissen würde er
macht 58 ich will gar nicht nach kugel
leute ihr könnt euch selber denken wie
viel wurde das ist dann eben richtig
video ein paar mal geflucht haben und
auch regen fanden genug hat die
sternkarte erwähnt hat muss sagen sehr
viel glück ich glaube ich habe mit die
höchste cpm in deutschland also ich
krieg pro 1000 klicks im durchschnitt
sieben bis zehn euro anstatt einen euro
also ich hab taste zehnfach höhere
cpm/sda
und wenn es also ich sag euch so jetzt
gerade ist die schwache werbezeiten wenn
man jetzt noch auf dezember guckt also
wenn man solche guckt dezember november
ist die da geht's aufs doppelte höher
das könnte das kann ja deswegen habe ich
natürlich auch ein paar regentage kauft
ihr wisst bescheid
dagmar kolb gaming series aus brüssel
zurück in die schweiz und tränen sagt
das heißt wir kommen auf die insel auf
seinen nacken natürlich bald wenn die
insel komplett gekauftes leute dann
machen wir diesen dann machen wir
zuschauer kräftiger erhalten wir
erhalten wir ein grundstück fall ist
kann ja gar nicht viel
das geht aber deutlich besser aus bei
dem anderen video mit 2,4 millionen dass
ich mit standards gemacht hat und zwar
haben wir jetzt zwei das video sieht
deutsches ist nicht gespannt
es war ein bisschen auch nicht viel
besser und der staat wie deo hat
ungefähr gleichen kriegst das hat
bestimmt viel mehr gebracht spielstand 1
4 million klicks und 1300 euro es ist
fast doppelt sovielen aber immer noch
das fast doppelt so viel wie das reh
video ist immer noch nicht die volle 1
euro cbm die man sagt im durchschnitt
aber ist es schon auf jeden fall besser
meinte travel news was immer noch recht
wenig ist das ist der cp m von 50 cent
unter also fast die hälfte von von der
die man sagt normalerweise ist das blaue
piste krank bin und war davor auch nicht
auf die youtube klicks angewiesen und
jetzt leute jetzt jetzt mal hin wenn ihr
euch als praktikant die behinderungen
denn davon leben die ich habe zum
beispiel der schnittkurs gemacht wo ich
und wie schneiden all bringen
da ist einfach da habt ihr das gesehen
das will ich ja cool denn wenn man einen
wenn man ein vernünftiges ein
vernünftiges online produkt auf den
markt
er hat es bisher wirklich leuten hilft
was man wo man hinter steht das nicht
irgendwie des camps gibt ja so viele die
macht das game scheiße aber machen keine
camper ist das und wenn er senke chor
rufen liebe das kann man es dann kaufen
und angucken da lernt man selber was da
zu bieten so eine schul kurs das ist
theoretisch der beste weg um geld
verdienen weil das ja skalierbar
es könnten sich jetzt diesen online kurs
den er gemacht hat könnten sich t
millionen leute kaufen bitte einfach mal
zehn millionen leute kaufen ich finds
echt geil also er hatte von rechts wie
gesagt ist eskaliert war ich muss mir
dafür dienen einen zusätzlich mehr habe
machen auch wenn sich jetzt million
leute kaufen würden
wer gleich viel arbeit und es fühlt sich
einfach richtig geil und ich finde auch
geld durch youtube werbung oder durch
instagram placement geld zu verdienen
ist natürlich auch neues aber durch so
ein kurs geld zu gehen wo man richtig
richtig viel arbeit reingesteckt aber
man weiß okay
derjenige der lernt er richtig viel und
gibt es zwar ein stück geld aus aber er
hat vielmehr value dann wieder zurück
gekriegt hat das für sie einmal richtig
man wirklich und absolut verdient weil
er hat ahnung von schneiden andeuten
dass bei nimmt damit nebenbei geld ein
super sache stop und der so richtig
richtig gut und ich werde euch der kurs
bringt euch wirklich viel da gibt's
nicht aktuell mit dem kreisel wieder 25
prozent rabatt nur übers wochenende und
wenn er doch der geht übrigens immer
noch leute direkt ihr wisst bescheid
lust auf meinen eigenen absolut reist
kann mein glück zu erwarten also wenn
ihr abschneiden lernen wollte sechs mal
aus weil er ist einer der leute wo man
bei ist die akquise wirkung nicht einmal
direkt wie sich das auf meine kurse
ausgewirkt hat also wir haben jetzt hier
ungefähr 200 neue user dazu gelegt und
seitdem er darauf reagiert haben sich
fünf neue leute den kurs gegönnt und ich
gehe davon aus dass trauen viele leute
davon gekommen vier leute den kurs heißt
nein
dann checkt man das is called ab da
werde ganz wichtig minecraft diskurs
auch da hätte der aufgelaufenen gehalten
waren der server staates video dadurch
wie ich finde
abhängig ist von youtube sondern hat
auch seine anderen online business hat
worüber es läuft so aber das video wurde
eigentlich vorgeschlagen eigentlich man
leute wir sehen ja schon über zehn
minuten alt da an wo sich ja auf jeden
fall noch mal ein extra wieder machen
das doch mal klar ich habe vom meister
ungelernte oder der gute und von behren
dazu wahrscheinlich auch ein video
hochladen also wenn ihr das ganze sehen
wollt dann guckt euch bei mir oder
meinem guten freund an beide sind auf
jeden fall verlinkt ich will nicht
weiter aufhalten wenn ich auf dieser
reise begleiten möchte dann schauen wir
bei ungefähr war erst ein mann und bei
mir auch ganz gut
[Musik]